foreign
[Music]
this is a big one
Mr Kusha okay
well let's play Let's Play Let's Play
serious opening
I think Mr crucial might be streaming so
cool pairing and we are facing a Karo
Khan so Mr Kusha is a very very strong
player so we are going to play
you know I'm gonna play my real stuff
I'm going to play a fantasy variation
which is what I have I think I've
already played it in in the speed run
we're gonna play a fantasy okay and Mr
Cruiser responds with one of the most
reputable lines against the fantasy the
E5 variation the point is that D takes
E5 runs into Queen H4 check so in this
position it is important to proceed with
Knight F3 this is theory
and Bishop G4 yeah so this is the
recommendation in
I think quite a few books this bishop G4
variation
and it's incredibly solid so white has
many different ways of
reacting to to this variation I'm a
little bit Rusty on the theory
but as far as I remember the move in
this position yeah so Bishop C4
Bishop C4 is a move and it's actually I
think the main move uh threatening
Bishop takes F7 and Knight takes C5 so
after Bishop C4 I think Black Goes
Knight D7
in order to cover the E5 Square then
White Castles Black Goes Knight gf6 and
I'm sure Mr cushion knows
this Theory uh backwards and forwards
but there was a different move that I
had analyzed here which if memory serves
me right is C3
and I'm going to try to remember is it
C3 in this position what worries me
about C3 is actually the blackened grab
the pawn bishop takes F3 Queen takes F3
and E takes D4 and I'm hunting for the
compensation
you know what let's play Bishop C4 let's
let's stick to what I know is fine
okay Knight D7 I'm definitely out of my
league here Theory wise
all right now I think we should probably
Castle
and keep developing
let's see what Kusha comes up with here
Knight gf6 okay
so this is the line
and now the point is if white plays D5
then black responds with Bishop takes F3
and recaptures the pawn in E5 so
what we should do here
is support the D4 Pawn because black is
constantly sort of threatening he takes
D4 so as far as I know the move is C3
so far I'm pretty confident okay but
Kusha knows this line clearly very very
well
we're going to try to take black out of
theory here because uh this this will
not be an interesting game if you know I
just get caught in in crazy deep
preparation
so
let's think what can we do here
well we can play Bishop G5
we can play Bishop G5
and then Knight pd2 or we can play
Knight bd2 immediately the drawback of
playing Knight bd2 is that it blocks the
bishop on C1
I'm leaning toward developing the bishop
first and then playing Knight pd2
we can also play a move we can also play
the move Queen to E1 in order to get the
queen out of the pin so that our Knight
has more Mobility
I quite like the look of Queen E1
actually it's a pretty flexible move it
solidifies the center it takes the sting
out of e takes D4
hopefully we can get our opponent out of
theory with this move
I mean if Mr crucial responds instantly
then he's the foremost Karo Khan expert
in the world okay looks like we've
finally gotten our opponent to think by
the way those watching on YouTube Mr
Kusha is a frequent guest of the stream
uh he's a streamer himself as you can
see by his account name and he might be
streaming this very game
so Queen E1 is a very logical appearing
move to me because why is it important
to unpin the Knight well because if
black develops the dark squared Bishop
to D6 one typical idea in such positions
is Knight H4 and Knight F5 and maybe the
queen later on can swing to G3 so the
fantasy variation is an attacking line a
tactical weapon and we want to play it
in the spirit of the line we want to go
for Attack on the king side
oh he's not streaming okay
and this is going to be a very serious
game because she was a very very strong
player and
um we're gonna try to play you know our
very best
I I didn't like Queen B3 because it
didn't really create a threat remember
that F7 is protected by Black's Bishop
so Queen B3 I thought might just run
into B5 and here if black plays B5 we
have the B3 Square for the bishop well
it's very important to keep this bishop
on this diagonal in order to pressure
the F7 Pawn which currently is well
defended but later on could become a
weakness also Knight takes E4 fails for
tactical reasons which I'll show after
the game
yeah I was aware that the pawn 94 was
hanging and uh it certainly could not
have been captured
I am expecting what am I expecting I I'm
expecting
Bishop f8 to D6 maybe he's thinking
about Bishop E7 a more modest
developing I don't know
yeah Queenie one is I actually really
Like Queenie one I think it's a it's a
it's a dangerous move Bishop takes F3
okay so that's a big move
that's a big move
um Kusha gets rid of our Knight in
return he's he gets rid of a very
important piece as far as I know the
light scored Bishop in such positions uh
is an integral Defender because without
it F7 becomes pretty weak and our Bishop
is now uncontested it's happy how are we
going to recapture so this is actually
not a given most of you are probably
thinking well obviously Rook takes F3
but there is a case to be made in
similar positions for the move GF why
because well there's two things GF
solidifies the E4 pawn it opens the G
file so we have this idea and it
potentially prepares to knock the E5
Pawn out of its not off the board with
F3 F4 so given the black hasn't
completed his kingside development GF is
a serious alternative but I'm not in an
overly adventurous mood right now
so I am more in the mood for Rook takes
F3
I'm more in the mood for the
conventional Rook takes F3 Bishop D6
okay well the thing is Kusha pre-moves
Bishop D6 so GF would have actually been
like basically winning because Bishop D6
F4 and we fork in with E5 but that's not
how we want to win the game that's not
how we want to win
uh with a dirty you know pre-move trick
Bishop D6 okay
so let's continue pondering how we want
to accumulate our pieces on the king
side a couple of candidate moves come to
mind so the obvious move is Bishop G5
just developing the bishop okay that's
fine
but we're not really attacking the
Knight because the two knights are
defending each other the other move that
comes to mind is Queen to H4
just bringing the queen to the king side
and preparing uh preparing to attack in
case black Castle's King side which I
think he will
okay we don't want to go Knight D2 I
don't want to obstruct the bishop the
what worries me about Bishop G5 is that
black has this annoying move Queen B6
hitting D4 and hitting B2 at the same
time
so perhaps a more flexible move is
needed
although after Queen H4 there's still
Queen B6 Queen B6 is just a generally
very annoying threat Queen B6 is a very
annoying threat
so let's think Bishop G5 Queen B6
let's see if we can spot a response to
that move
yeah Queen F2 Maybe
then ah Queen F2 maybe actually yeah
oh that looks good
that does look good Bishop G5 Queen B6
Queen F2
and if Knight takes E4 then we can snap
off the F7 pawn and the king is in huge
trouble there okay I'm sold let's go
Bishop G5
I mean this is a little bit flimsy
the way we're playing this is flimsy but
it's it's the fantasy variation what do
you expect it it is also potentially
very rewarding because we have the
center if we manage to complete our
development successfully we're gonna be
better no question about it but we run
the risk of our Center collapsing and if
our Center collapses will be in huge
trouble if we lose the D4 Pawn Black's
Knight is going to jump into this juicy
E5 square and we're gonna be dead so
very important to be accurate here with
white
I will be honest I'm regretting
I'm regretting not playing GF I think GF
was better actually
I think GF might have been better but
we'll roll with it Bishop G5 is on the
board too late now
all right
so what am I expecting here I'm
expecting either Castle's kingside or
queen B6
there's probably other moves black could
throw in H6 we're just going to play
Bishop H4
I don't really know who this benefits at
this point the
next move of course is Knight b182 we
want to complete our development it
would also be kind of nice if we could
throw in the move King H1 so that in
case black does play Queen B6
we don't have the additional worry of
the Pawn on D4 being pinned we have a
little bit more flexibility in that case
but yeah Kusha is probably deciding
between these these moves
it's a pretty simple position to
understand like it's it's clear what the
battle is revolving around here there's
no mystery as to like what we're playing
for I'm playing to complete the
development and start the king side
attack once black castles and Kusha is
trying to hit me where it hurts while I
haven't completed while I haven't yet
completed the development the question
who's going whose strategy is going to
prevail
we'll see might very well be his
yeah it's an interesting interesting
position definitely would be a lot to
analyze after the game Queen C7 okay
we can see seven I did not expect but
it's also a very reasonable move and
maybe he wants to Castle queenside
that is not something I've given enough
attention to Castle's Queen said Okay so
why don't we just play Knight T2 well
what we have to reckon with is he takes
C takes and Bishop takes H2 check but I
think that's a worthy Pawn to sacrifice
because he takes D4 is a massive
concession it gives us a juicy Center
I'm more than willing to part ways with
a corner Pawn if that means we get full
control of the center so I think Knight
D2 is essentially a no-brainer Rook f8
okay so definitely he's telegraphing
that he's preparing Castle's Queen side
yeah the point of Rook f8 is to defend
F7 so let's think how are we going to
try to deter or we can't deter council's
Queen side there's no way to prevent it
but we can probably prepare for it okay
I have an interesting idea
this is an idea that combines tactics
and positional play
so as I've already said our main worry
is the center right we need to keep our
Center under control at all costs so I
have this idea of playing Bishop C4 to
D3 and I know this is a move most of you
will be like really you know didn't I
just say the bishop is crucial to keep
on this day I know well the
circumstances have changed now F7 is no
longer a weakness especially since black
is going to Castle queenside and I think
it's more important for us to make sure
that the center is well protected but
there's another idea we're going to make
this move because our time is ticking
that I think it's more important for the
Knight to have the C4 Square than it is
for the bishop I think Knight D2 to C4
is going to come with greater effect if
black Castle's Queen side then keeping
the bishop on C4
and it's also very solid move because
what am I anticipating I am anticipating
him putting a rook on E8
after he castles Queen side and so our
Pawn on e4 is going to be nicely
protected in that case leaving the
Knight FREE to pursue a more active
agenda on C4 what is it doing on C4 well
it's obviously pressuring the bishop and
the E5 pawn and I absolutely will take
that Bishop to give us two Bishops
against two knights if he allows it yeah
of course I'm not excluding the
possibility of a pond storm but Pond
storms are slow and cumbersome they're
generally overrated and it's not like if
we get a pawn to A6 it's checking you
know people have a hard time
understanding that pawn storms are very
cumbersome devices it usually takes
three moves to get your Pawn to where it
wants to be and then it's not like it's
made you actually just provoke
weaknesses then you actually have to
mount the attack
I've talked about this before when
there's an opposite side castling
situation a lot of people just sort of
indiscriminately go all right it's time
to go B4 and A4 and B5 that's not the
only way to approach opposite side
castling positions you can also play
with your pieces that's not forbidden
and that's what we're doing here Knight
D2 to C4 notice that we're still
sacrificing the H2 Pawn if he wants he
can still play Ed Bishop H2 but nothing
has changed we will still have a monster
Center and black will have logistical
problems getting the bishop back out of
H2 as I'll show you after the game
so the caveman attack has a time and
place am I saying
you know you never pawn star absolutely
not Pawn storms are great but not in
every circumcision Rook d a great move
because we're playing extremely well as
expected let's think I'm just gonna
think in silence here for a bit
I think I know what I want to play but
I'm confirming
okay
I'm gonna make the move Queen G3
and everybody should understand the
intention of this move
um the intention of this move is to
prevent E takes D4 now you say wait wait
a second didn't I just say that I want
to encourage he takes D4 well again this
is a very dynamic position what does it
mean for a position to be dynamic it's a
lot of things change on every move I
think that's a good definition of
dynamic that means stuff that was true
in the previous move is no longer true
things that weren't a threat are now a
threat I'm now a lot more worried about
e takes D4 because this is an x-ray
against my queen you can already
probably spot Knight takes C4 and F5
related ideas so now he takes D4 is a
bigger enemy and so Queen G3 gets the
queen onto a good square and it prevents
ed4 because Knight takes D6 wins the
bishop with check if black plays Knight
H5 which probably worries some of you
it's not something to be worried about
the queen can tuck itself away on H3 and
H3 is a great Square it's out of the way
of the other pieces and it's x-raying
the Knight on D7
and uh I I like the way that I've
arranged my pieces here I think we're
starting maybe I'm gonna jinx it but I
think I'm starting to get control over
this game
uh but there's a ton of work yet to be
done both of us are taking quite a long
time so this might actually come down to
a Time scramble
no I think I think at this point white
is definitely better
but black is incredibly solid that is
the karaoke after all
okay rookie six I am aware that it's a
move but rookie 6 we can take the bishop
rookie six remember that we can also
take the bishop it's like jumping off at
the last moment right
we can take the bishop when we want to
take it
yeah very tight and notice the work
that's being done by the bishop on D3
it's a purely defensive piece defensive
pieces are underrated
right and that's why I put it there so
that it defends the pawn on e4 don't
have to worry about it IG it okay so I
guess kusho wants to move F6 or maybe
even F5
interesting
I'm going to take another couple of
moments in silence here to think
this is very complicated even for me I'm
not hiding that
so this the the tempting move to me is
Rook af1 but that kind of runs into F6
that kind of runs into F6 so maybe we I
mean black can play F6 anyway but maybe
we don't want to provoke it maybe you
want to drop the bishop away from G5 how
about that idea Bishop E3
I like Bishop E3 a lot why do I like
Bishop B3 a lot because again it
solidifies the center and it attacks the
pawn on G7 I like the look of Bishop E3
I think the bishop has done its job on
G5 it's now time to adopt a more
defensive posture
now the pawn on G7 is hanging that's our
first threat and G6 is a pretty
significant weakness that perhaps later
on we can try to exploit
looks like Black's position is just
starting to show some cracks but we have
to figure out a way to exploit those
cracks now
F5 is not a threat
we can take the bishop but I don't think
there's any hurry
maybe there is a hurry maybe if we don't
take it the bishop will drop back to E7
and I'll regret it so one idea that I
have is to play Rook af1 induce the move
F6 then take the bishop and then
reposition the bishop back to C4
or move the queen away to H3
or start pushing the pawns and launch
the pawn storm
A4 even here is pretty tempting by the
way just pushing the pawn creating
you know grabbing space on the queen
side
all right my gut is telling me what is
my God is not actually telling me
anything
okay let's go okay F1 let's start by
doubling we have to also speed up a
little bit Gucci is a very fast player
okay I have an idea to play Queen H3 and
x-ray the Knight how about that let's go
Queen H3
attacking H7 and x-raying the Knight why
is it good to x-ray the Knight well what
is the Knight doing well one of the
things the night's doing is it's
protecting E5 and it's protecting F6 so
Quinn H3 puts more strain on those Pawns
and that may lead us to an unexpected
tactic right when you're putting a lot
of strain on your opponent's position
that's what creates the preconditions
for a sudden tactic that might seemingly
come out of nowhere but it doesn't
actually come out of nowhere it's just
because you've been pressuring and
pressuring and eventually something's
got to give
why not Queen H3 before Rook F1 I mean
it was possible actually maybe it was
even better to play Queen H3 first but I
wanted to induce another weakness I
wanted the pawn to sit on F6 which
restricts the mobility of the Knight on
G8 maybe the immediate Queen H3 was in
fact better I don't know it's hard to
say
am I worried about black Pond storming
not particularly
there's not too much that I'm worried
about in this position I think we're
super neat and tidy
and I don't see any danger to my own
King okay we're also getting Kusha to
think which is good the time is ticking
down for both of us
and we're only 18 Moves In yeah I'm
regretting a little bit well no Rook a
F1 I think cannot be such a bad move I
mean after all we're bringing the Rook
into the game all of our pieces are
doing something which basically means
that we can't really be worse here
yeah everything's going on on the center
in the king so the queen side is a dead
zone right now rookie seven okay
I think that's a tactical blunder
ladies and gentlemen I think I think
Kusha has just given us a chance to win
material
now I mentioned previously that we're
x-raying the night on D7 well
what move becomes uh more serious now
that we're doing that well the move D
takes E5 which previously just allowed
black to occupy the Outpost now needs to
be considered so we are going to play D
takes C5 Knight E5 is illegal F take C5
loses The Rook on f8 hence the reason we
doubled and Bishop takes E5 what do I
notice I noticed that there's an
alignment of the two Rooks what does
that tell us well we should look for
Pins Bishop C5 but that blunder is the
bishop no it doesn't because the Knight
on D7 is pinned
we are going to play
Bishop C5 now there's a yeah Bishop H2 I
saw that move and of course we play King
H1 of course we play King H1
we don't take on H2 because then black
takes and takes C5 I did see that move
and this game is also not over this game
is far from over I think we're
technically winning after this
but black still has a very solid
position so we still need to demonstrate
some good technique
Bishop B5 now
okay
so we have several ways to approach this
we have several ways to approach this
I'm trying to find a Knockout blow I'm
trying to find a win so we could take
care of another queen takes let's take
the Rook let's take the Rook we could
take this Pawn but then I'm really
worried about a pin down the H file the
other candidate move is to take on E5
induce Queen takes E5 and then shift The
Rook over to D1 in order to mount
pressure on the Knight on D7 I'm also
very tempted by the look of Queen to E6
I mean look at how sexy that move looks
Queen E6 are you kidding me
sticking the queen right into Black's
Grill doesn't that look good let's go
Queen E6 I'm just playing this is a
purely intuitive move I did zero
calculation full disclosure it just like
it's just begging to be played I mean it
just like puts so much additional strain
on black position and it just keeps the
initiative going
how does the CM blunder so easily well I
don't think that was an obvious Blender
at all I think he reacted very well to
it and this has been an incredibly
complicated game handled very well by
our opponent so let's relax so Rook F6
almost works
Rook F6 almost Works 95 Queen E5 I don't
want Queen F7 Queen d8 wow let me think
Rook F6 Bishop F6 Knight D6 king da we
have a draw
obviously I don't want to draw
we want to win
oh
oh my gosh I see something really cool
but does it work
oh man this if this works it's gonna be
really pretty
I don't know if it works though
gotta work
I'm thinking about something really
really pretty let me just calculate
yeah I'm gonna go for it I'm gonna go
for it Rook takes F6 you guys are all
seeing it so I won't even introduce a
rook F6
yeah but it's not as easy I know most of
you think this is easily winning but
it's actually not
and I'm pretty sure we're going to
follow the line the best he's going to
find all the best moves because there's
not really not much of a choice for
black
so I'm still thinking about how to win
in the critical position
it looks completely winning but it's
somehow black is surviving there I don't
even understand how
yeah now Knight D6 intermezzo
and Rook takes F6
and Rook takes F6 if Knight F6 black
gets checkmated
the problem is placas Rook a fade
and somehow
lack is holding on for dear life
okay I think I see the no man
it's frustrating
every time I think I see the wind some
dumb defense pops up
yeah Rook f8 Knight F7 King Y8
and again black is surviving ah but then
maybe Rook F3 simply
no Rook I faded Knight F7 then King E8
no no Knight F7 King E8
I I'm I'm leaning toward Knight F7 King
8 and Rook F3 I think that's got to be
winning
I think it's got to be the win
I mean there's Knight F7 you can play
without any risk
because if King C8 then Queen takes C7
and we hit the Rook
so Knight F6 doesn't work so King E8 is
forced of course black and also sack on
F7 but then we're simply up a full
exchange and we're mating
so now the idea is to play Rook F3 this
is a move that I'll have to explain in
depth after the game basically I'm
trying to keep the tension and I'm
trying to keep the pressure on Black's
position Fully Alive
and I reserved the ability to play
Knight T6 whenever whenever I want so
the Knight on D7 is immobilized because
if it moves then Knight D6 leads to an
instant loss The Rook on f8 will be lost
the Knight on E7 is pinned The Rook on
f8 is no Prospect so the only piece that
can really move for black is the Queen
the move I'm struggling to refute is
Queen B6 not because it does anything
but just because it is the only way to
move but in that position we have time
and I think I can put my time to good
use and activate the bishop or I could
just play B4 and restrict black even
further
oh there's such a gorgeous line there oh
I see some cool stuff wait let me think
ah
so unfortunate that none of it quite
seems to work
I think I see okay Rook G8 it's not what
I expected
not what I expect so Knight D6 again it
goes there we can repeat once if we
wanted to
96 King d8 Rook F7
95 rookie seven and mate wait that's
promising he's got all right C5 ah
let's get Knight C5
okay so maybe just B4
maybe B4 through stop Knight C5
I think B4 makes sense here
Rook G7
playing very quickly which is
disconcerting because I'm low on time
okay I'm tempted to play Bishop C4 even
though I don't know exactly why
E5 is also interesting
yeah E5 is very interesting I think E5
might be the move I don't know why
exactly just yet
I just don't see a move for black here
because Knight f8 loses to Knight D6
yeah I think he fighted what does E5 do
I mean E5 just like drives another Pawn
into the position and anchors it anchors
the D6 Square so that after Knight D6
check our Queen is free to roam about
the cabin
and produce tactical ideas like for
example Knight D6 check King d8 and Rook
F7 this post game analysis is going to
be juicy so don't go anywhere
um there's so much I have to explain
so my actual threat here is Knight D6
check okay Queen B6 now he plays it
now he plays it okay now let me think
this is I need to solve one last hurdle
here
Mighty 16 d8 we're good seven takes
takes let's think
I think that's a win because he can't
stop Queenie it if 95 Queen E8 can C7
Queen E7 so let's calculate Knight D6
King d8 Rook F7 takes takes Knight moves
now Queen E8 of 95 Queen E8 of Queen E3
Queen e oh my God Queen E3 Queen EA
Queen C8 Knight no it doesn't work
oh my god he has Queen E3 there
my gosh
it's holding on
before it might be the move
this is honestly it's unreal to me that
there's like no
immediate win I think there is I'm just
not seeing it
A5 yeah
okay I could take it
when 96
maybe a three and we go for zugs one
all right I'm gonna take it I'm gonna
take one
maybe I should have I should have just
gone Queen D6 it was winning
this one or Rook D3 oh Rook D3 was just
winning oh no
Rook D3 was so easy
oh yeah
that's criminal that I didn't see that
let's just check yeah
okay I guess Rook F1
and Rook D1 maybe I can repeat the same
idea
remember Rook
huh
okay let's go Rook F1
this is simply phenomenal defense by
question it's just phenomenal
the way he's surviving this is crazy
but I think his time might be coming to
an end if I can find like one more move
and I think that one more move is Rook
to D1 we switch to the D file
and the point is that if the Knight
moves we made on d8
this is not spectacular but I think it's
going to get the job done which is more
important in such positions
I think this is the final straw that
broke the camel's back I think this is
this is over I mean he's been finding
incredible resources yeah King f8 is
very resilient because now if we play
Rook D7
if we play Rook D7 then there's Queen C1
but we play Queen D7 we don't give black
any checks down the back Rank and it's
over oh what a game
this was probably maybe top three in
terms of most complicated games
um a lot to talk about and a lot
remained behind the scenes that's the
frustrating thing about these types of
games is that a lot of the most
beautiful lines remain behind the scenes
yeah it was winning
okay it was just completely winning
actually it was like plus a million
okay gg gg crucial
so this was a Karo Khan we played into
the fantasy variation I don't really
know
whether I had business going into the
fantasy without having reviewed it prior
but I was hoping that Kusha wouldn't go
into this line take stakes in E5
now we have mostly faced and Blitz and
stuff the move E6
E6 is I think the most popular move
these days and it leads to uh kind of a
french-like structure which is not to
everybody's liking the main line is
Knight C3 Bishop before now very
fashionable is the move Bishop D3 which
is a pawn sack uh it's a pawn sack black
can take and take on D4 but white gets
what does white get white gets massive
development and the f file which can be
used when you Castle shorts there's a
lot of theory here that you could uh dig
around and queen B6 is even a
fashionable move as well of course
there's there's G6 which is a solid line
uh but D takes E4 and E5 is incredibly
principled this is the most principled
Line This is the most principled line
yeah Kush if you want to call and
analyze I'm totally fine with that
all right sure
all right so for those watching on
YouTube my opponent is going to be
calling me
and we're going to be analyzing the game
together it's gonna be fun
hey
hey how's it going
going well uh thanks for thanks for
thanks for calling this is I think it's
gonna be a lot of fun this will be a
great honor for me and a great
opportunity of course don't don't
mention it this is this is great so I
was pretty Rusty on this line after
Bishop G4 I think this was the first
like interesting moment I was debating
between C3 and Bishop C4 what do you
what do you know here
so I know that after C3 Bishop takes F3
Queen takes F3 takes D4 the lines are a
little bit dangerous for black so this
is not what I usually play
uh I actually don't know that much like
I think there's
I'm looking at engine now there's Bishop
C4 so I I was planning to play Knight D7
regardless against C3
aha 97 yeah that's sort of what I
remembered and now the bishop can come
out to E2
I think this is an alternate alternate
development in the Knight F6 castles
six yeah Knight bd2 this is actually the
lion castles and Knight C4
interesting
and now it wasn't familiar with this
line honestly
I I haven't faced it that much like 90
of people who I play they play Bishop C4
after Bishop G4
aha yeah no I I knew it was the main
line but I didn't know much about it so
I was on my own after Bishop C4
so 97
castles I think is pretty logical
uh this all seems pretty much for us
Knight F6 and C3 a lot of people were
wondering why not Knight takes C4 here
I'll just show that Bishop takes F7 is
totally crushing
and King takes F7 Knight takes E5 is a
double check
and the bishop on G4 is lost so he
weren't you weren't tempted to take the
pawn
so I actually want to show a line if you
don't mind so of course I know I know
there's a line with Bishop D6 where
Black or White can actually win a pawn
with Queen B3 castles Queen B7 but black
gets some massive compensation so if
Bishop takes F3 sorry yeah it's the
analysis board is kind of chanky so I'm
I'm making the moves on my end as well
Queen takes place seven
Bishop takes F3 and I didn't recall the
rest of the line like I haven't played
it in a while but I remember that this
is pretty good for black
yeah I mean I think with the lack of
development on the queen side I'm the
engine is giving Rook F3 edcd and now
Knight G4
yeah this is not to my liking E5 there's
going to be 95 and Bishop C5 and queen
is coming to D1 yeah this is
this is game over
yeah I didn't remember the details so I
decided to go with a more solid Bishop
H5 which meets Queen B3 would be five
right that I I was reasoning during the
game I thought that was the point Queen
B3 B5 and the bishop has to leave the
diagonal which is undesirable
so originally after Bishop H5 my
intention was Bishop G5
but somehow I was very worried about
Queen B6 there
like this queen B6 idea is very annoying
in these types of positions I think
yeah sure
so I don't know what you would have done
after Bishop G5 but oh Bishop E7 I think
is also fine
yeah usually like white can't take on E5
because always I'm gonna take bishop
f395 and
and queen C7 castles pretty solid for
black I think
a grade agreed so Queenie one I thought
was more flexible
you took on F3 which
I wasn't
like necessary I think Bishop D6 were
you worried about Knight H4 and like
Knight F5 yeah that's one of the things
I was worried off and also like
some points maybe some Bishop G5
like Bishop G5 combined with Knight H4
puts a lot of pressure on F6 and five
might be a weak Square so
I was kind of worried about these kinds
of
and I'm sorry I really didn't like to
give up my light squared Bishop but
these things worried me a lot
yeah I was I was actually going to play
the immediate Knight H4 and this looked
very juicy especially a few Castle
kingside so I I tend to agree like this
position after Knight H4 cast I don't
know if you can see my moves yeah yeah
of course I can oh okay cool it's just
weirdly I can't see yours but okay but
this position I just thought is like
you know super fun to play for white
surely so I think Bishop F3 was a pretty
wise decision Rook F3 and Bishop D6
you're super solid here
yeah but again the best one C4 is is now
a God it was really annoying to deal
with it yeah it's totally uncontested
and I I it didn't even occur to me that
you could Castle queenside until
honestly until you played Queen C7
so like I I totally forgot about that
concept and I started to get worried
about my Center
I see uh by the way I forgot to mention
something you pre-moved Bishop D6 but I
actually was seriously considering GF
I then Primo Bishop D6 oh okay you just
played quickly but yeah it's funny
because
yeah yeah I saw that I was planning to
go Bishop E7 against gf3 aha
and if I go F4 anyway
uh this one I I think I
yeah that that looks really bad at least
I'm not losing a piece right away
yeah it's weird it also looks annoying
so I'll just show everybody that this
this loses because whichever Pawn you
take the other you know the other Pawn
defends E5 and black just ends up losing
the game on the Spot Classic idea yeah
Bishop B7 F4 takes E5
I mean at the very least looks like a
strong initiative or just Bishop takes
F4
yeah Bishop F4 looks more annoying to me
because it doesn't give me the D5 Square
aha
that's a fair point yeah Bishop B7 here
here and then Knight D2 now White's got
to be better in this position with such
a center the reason I ultimately didn't
play GF I didn't mention this to my chat
but it was actually this move Knight H5
I didn't even think about Knight H5
honestly uh-huh
I guess it's just F4 is so strong that I
think stopping it at all cost is
important
sure although does this really stop F4
I'm not sure but anyways does GF
something to chew on
uh also there was GF Knight B6 and E
takes D4 which I wasn't sure about
yeah this one this one I did consider
actually this one I I I I was planning
to think more after gf3 I wasn't
planning to play quickly but Bishop isan
was my first intention but Knight B6 was
something I saw as well
but it's a possibility yeah maybe this
just refutes GF because I think I have
to move the bishop and then Ed
and I'm not sold on White's compensation
because 55 then like you again as you
mentioned black gets the D5 Square
so I thought this was a little bit too
late
you mean yeah I mean actually after Rook
F3 you you still have Knight B6 but here
I think it's a lot more dangerous after
Bishop b3ed I think E5 is good for white
this one seemed seemed really sketchy to
me
agreed so Bishop D6 Bishop G5 okay so
Queen C7
Knight D2 like I assume you didn't
seriously think about taking H2 no I
never did because the detector is just
crushing your five is coming
yeah I'll show this on the board just
for the chat here here and actually the
bishop has nowhere to go
because E5 is coming next
so even if the bishop is not lost I
think this is crushing
yeah if Seven's week the Rooks x-raying
no this is terrible so Rook f8 defends
the pawn and prepares to Castle
and here I thought for a while like I
wasn't totally sure how to defend
against the plan of castles in rookie
eight but I came up with this idea that
I kind of liked which is Bishop D3 and
Knight C4
yeah and I think it was a really
powerful idea
so I castled pretty quickly but after
Knight C4 I was debating between Bishop
E7 and Rook d8 but
and after Bishop E7 I felt like control
over the center is not going to be as
powerful compared to Rook d8
and I was worried that in some lines
like not right away but in some lines
you might take 25 and use some pin with
Bishop F4 or something
so I felt like Rook d8 is is more solid
I agree I also I can just start like
pushing and if he takes D4 Bishop F4
literally traps the queen traps the
queen wow crazy line so here I feel like
black is at a standstill while white is
like starting to push I think Rook d8 is
is the best practical decision
uh but it's already kind of unpleasant
after Queen G3
yeah I didn't came up with anything
better than Knight G8 because F7 Pawn is
backwards and if you get through kf1
and I can never ever move that Knight
away
that's a good point
uh yeah that was the plan
yeah if you give me time to go Knight G8
F6 rookie 7 without provoking more
weaknesses I think black is holding but
I just didn't have enough time
yeah I wanted I wasn't sure where I was
going with this but I thought okay I'll
provoke all these weaknesses and queen
H3 is an important move because it ties
you down further and now de becomes a
big problem
yeah like here I know I blundered like
an exchange but
um
I don't see a way to to to save material
it's not so easy maybe H5 but that looks
really ugly
yeah I was expecting H5 and then I was
seriously considering D anyway
so Bishop E5
and actually I also have like 90 yeah
yeah maybe 95 first and then Bishop A7
yeah or but I think this also helps
create the threat of Knight B6 so I was
more enticed by that but yeah 95 Bishop
A7 also looks great I mean a pawn is a
pawn and you know you're still super
tied down
yeah and and again two Bishops versus
two knights that's that's also really uh
really really annoying to play
yeah in such a position agreed people uh
resting for us as king ba was necessary
at some point after castles but I don't
think you had a chance to play it yeah I
just didn't have time I think you played
really well with uh with initiative I
think that's that's a very good game to
uh to show to people to understand like
the power of the initiative not giving
opponent time to consolidate
yeah I appreciate that uh you defended
like a monster though after after I won
the exchange I kind of thought it was
over
uh Bishop H2 is a really nice move I'll
just show that Queen takes H2 is
terrible because there's no longer the
pin on the Knight and now Knight C5 is
possible
so at least you get a pawn
yeah
and I think a lot of people in this
position would have just sort of taken
any five and kind of relaxed but if you
can move your king and go Knight C5
you're super solid in the center I
assume you were kind of hoping for
something like that
yeah I think that's not so easy to win
actually like maybe for you it's so easy
but uh in general I have some practical
chances because E4 is an isolated Pawn
as well maybe I can pressure it with
adding the other Knight to D6 given time
of course
yeah and if I if I can get pawns on the
dark squares for instance because you
have just one dark light squared Bishop
maybe I can get some sort of blockade
and
50 Watts
yeah the dream is G5 h5h4
no but it's it's definitely not easy the
other thing I mean I was very tempted to
take but here there's this yeah yeah
such a nice move and Rook h8 is such a
big I mean I guess I have to play Rook
H3 and I'm still winning
yeah you're kind of tied down now maybe
maybe F no five thousand dollars maybe
B5
I I wasn't
going to be five but it looks
interesting
like I kept seeing these nightmare
scenarios like let's say takes takes
Bishop E2 then maybe G5 Knight G6 it's
definitely lost it's probably completely
lost
according to the engine but practically
it's not so simple in such positions I
mean this Knight is a monster
yeah surely but but you can you can
always go Queen G7 as well if
there's something happening on the H
file we can go clean G7
plus it it hits the pawn now I think
when H7 is a viable alternative but once
I saw Queen E6 I couldn't pull my eyes
away from it
yeah
um so rookie in his forced if you had
gone King d8
I think I can play Rook D1 creating just
a massive pressure on the Knight
no I think Ricky it is the best chance
and then I I saw Rook F6 Knight D6 and
Rook F6 and I just figured this has to
be winning
um if Knight F6 there's made in one yeah
so Rook f8 is forced what were your
thoughts in this position were you still
hoping to pull it out
um I mean if I was honestly if I was
playing against someone low rated surely
but uh
I I thought like at least I don't see uh
I don't see the wind right away that's
the point like just to give a give you a
story that uh for the viewers if they
like to I I recently had a game where I
played against somebody much lower rated
than myself and I was getting mated in a
situation like this
I called for myself to find
like I was refuting all the moves and
the one that took them the least clear I
was playing that I just kept fighting
kept hanging on until Conan made a
blunder and I won the game
yeah well that's uh
that's so true like people get flustered
when they don't see like a forced win
and they think a four stone has to exist
kind of like this position I was
definitely getting flustered
I see
um okay I cheated a little bit there is
a immediate win which I totally missed
it's Rook f8 Knight f8
and it's so funny I was only like
considering the F7 square but Queen F6
is just ends the game wow so if not this
time Queen h8 and you win at night
I guess wait what if
what if King D7
I guess just E5 is overwhelming E5
96
and what now
Bishop C4 probably oh shoot I see a cool
line Bishop C4 Knight C5 E6 and mate on
F4
I mean there's going to be all sorts of
lines like this in the end it's actually
mates Jesus yeah
yeah it's just me for a second I thought
you're just winning the queen then I
realized it's made I thought so too I
think this is all for so Bishop C4 can
you not move the Knight I guess you can
go Knight D5 but then I
I mean at a minimum
immediate Queen F7 just made it two
sure a queen E8 is made so this is this
was the fourth twin
yeah I missed Queen F6 uh my missed
Queen F6
so I decided like the best bet is just
to keep the Rooks on the board and keep
Knight D6 alive it really hurts you that
you can't move your knight because of
Knight D6 and Rock Cafe yeah exactly
that's why I played Rook G8 that was the
only thing that came to my mind just
preparing some Knight C5 Maybe
yeah that's I actually panicked a little
bit when I saw like Knight C5 is a very
strong threat as soon as I made a move
I realized that wait no Bishop C4 still
Knight C5 so I think B4 is very annoying
I was hoping for Knight D6 King d8 Rook
have seven Knight C5 where again I maybe
probably there's some win but
I I just couldn't see it or why
yeah no here it gets very complicated I
think I almost went for
I don't know what I I almost went for
some line like Bishop C4 looked so
tempting to me to create the X-ray but
here again Knight C5
Knight D6 King d8 and it's kind of a
dead end
although there's a crazy move Knight
takes B7 here
wow oh my God what a move none of these
are character to me but
I was 100 sure I'm completely lost but I
was just trying to play the moves which
uh
I didn't see the instant reputation to
them yeah you did an amazing job of that
like before Rook G7 again I I think I
have to play like a slow move like E5
and at this point I mean I'm just
closing in on you I think it's just too
cramped
but Queen B6 is another really good move
so here I almost went 96 and Rook F7
and my thought was that I'm threatening
Queen E8 and queen C mate but then I
realized the Knight controls that square
and you have time for Queen E3
wow it's actually a draw
yeah like Queen E8 Queen E7 I guess you
can just
you have maybe Perpetual or or like
Queen C1 Queen H6
yeah this looks like a Perpetual here
here
G1 Queen E3 incredible
so
you sometimes even can save games
against uh strong players from these
hopeless positions yeah it's like the
Magnus you know one survive one more
move A5 is another nice move
um but I think ba just puts too much
strain on your position
yeah I was desperately trying for some
counter play but it was non-existent
yeah if takes the Knight D6 and ip7 is a
fork that was the idea
Queen B1 Rook F1 yeah I think maybe
maybe your last like many chances to
play Queen C2 to stop Rook D1
I see
but here I was planning Knight D6 and
Knight takes B7 simply I mean I'm also
up like a million Pods at this point
yeah like
even if you trade everything you're
gonna win pretty easily I think maybe
like I I I'm also cheating a little bit
uh afterwards yeah maybe Queen takes F1
is the best chance yeah at first I
almost didn't play Rook F1 because of it
but then I thought Rook F7
oh I missed I thought Bishop C4 just
ends the game but I guess you have Rook
F5 and Rook takes C5 and suddenly you're
back in the game
this should be a technical win but uh
it asks some questions for sure
yeah I wonder what the eval is here it's
Plus
uh Queen D6 I have to find
rookie 5 and Bishop E6 yeah here
ah here you have to give the Rook away
yeah that should be pretty easy Bishop
C4 the top engine was Rook F4 actually
it's hard to play Rook F4 when you have
for cop 5 but
yeah now
Bishop back okay yeah definitely
technical win but maybe
could have stayed in the game a little
bit longer
yeah I I didn't fancy my chances in that
against someone like you for sure
well I mean the way you held on you
definitely put some data in my mind okay
yeah here obviously it's over
so I wonder like where where your like
big mistake was because it just seemed
like once you had castled Queen side it
was already unpleasant what are your
thoughts on that
uh so personally
honestly I don't know like it just felt
like I slowly got got out of play
maybe maybe the whole idea with Jocelyn
Queen side in this line is not great
like if it wasn't one move I think that
just completely changed the eval or
something
agreed completely I I actually think
maybe bishop takes F3 was the start of
your troubles because somehow the light
the light squares was always like a
hidden enemy for you I wonder what the
what the theory is okay we had Bishop D6
is the theory move
and then if Knight H4
the engine recommends ah Bishop G6 here
just to stop Knight F5
yeah
and in the event of a trade you get the
H file so now you get play against the
H2 Pawn here white is worse
yeah sure but you're never going to take
that
oh yeah no I I would probably play
Knight F5
I was worried about Knight F5 Bishop G5
and just seemed really really uh
practically hard to play these this
position but already here you can play
Ed CD and queen B6
so here you're starting to hit all my
pawns but 1964. oh wow
yeah
Queen f29 I think your white is already
in trouble all of a sudden
so probably I shouldn't go Knight F5
probably I should go
like Knight D2 or something
but obviously if you can make me play
Knight T2 before developing the bishop I
think you're okay to just Castle
yeah
so
after castles you might actually take on
G6 and play Knight F3 yep that's kind of
what I
my intuition says as well I think why
it's slightly better in all these
positions but
probably like my chat is also saying
Queen C7 on move 11 wasn't ideal okay so
as you said like maybe the Castle's
Queen side idea maybe just Castle
kingside
maybe the simplest approach is best I
actually honestly I play like I played a
lot online I
I faced literally every right every line
against Cairo like more than 20 times
and I usually Castle kingside in fantasy
but for some reason no longer time
control game I was scared I was like so
I'm gonna get pressed on the king side
Knight D2 Queen G2 rookie have fun like
this this all seemed really scary all
these pieces coming
Queen H4 of course Queen G3 there's some
ed4
um
yeah and
that was like a game time decision to
try long fast lane for the first time in
my life yeah it's a really interesting
plan I think the only reason black is
okay here is because of this idea take
stakes in Queen B6 and somehow black
holds on by a thread because E5 Queen D4
doesn't work you take on E5
and I think black gets enough counter
play here
yeah
like fantasy is really concrete you
can't just play by intuition most of the
time
yeah it is it is it's such a it's such a
rich variation
uh but it was such a fun game like once
you Castle the queen side
it was a it was a rich position and I
thought you defended uh really really
resiliently
yeah I'm usually known to be a resilient
defender in my games uh
and what what I really
what I'm really lacking in my game and I
really like to learn better is what you
did in the game perfectly like playing
with initiative not giving time for
opponents to consolidate
yeah and I think that was a very
instructive game for me as well to face
I appreciate that this yeah this is a
lot of fun to play
um I was fully focused probably more so
than any other speedrun game so
thank you for thank you for that
experience I I really appreciate it
you're welcome and uh it was a great
experience for me as well I swear to
talk to people of course I'll give you
another shout out I'll let you go but uh
thank you so thank you for uh for
analyzing me sir you're always welcome
have a great one Dania you too soon
again bye
bye
all right
I hope you guys enjoyed that's sort of
what you know analysis looks like at a
high level I know that it was fast paced
for some people so what I'm going to do
is go through a couple of the key
moments again more slowly
and just draw some conclusions because I
know that was a little bit all over the
place but again like that is what
analysis is like
uh you just sort of jump around for
moment to moment okay here I thought
this I thought that at the engine thinks
this
um and at the end of the day you just
form a better understanding of what your
opponent was thinking
um so for those watching on YouTube that
was my opponent uh very graciously
volunteered to call and analyze thanks
again
so let's uh hit on the main points of
this game so I played the fantasy gusher
responded with sort of one of the main
lines this bishop G4 variation
um Bishop C4 is the main move
and then sort of the battle started
revolving around the center now Knight
D7 here is important if black starts
with Knight F6 then there's the bishop
takes F7 tactic 95 and the Knight
Returns to take on G4
um so this is Theory castles Knight f63
and Bishop H5 to protect the F7 Pawn
and here I came up with this very
interesting idea that set everything in
motion Queen E1
in order to free the night Bishop F3
Rook F3
and we have determined I think that the
actual main mistake was the plan with
long castles like why was long castles
conceptually the wrong plan I think what
it has to do with is the fact that
Black's kingside pawns are actually
weaker than they look
the F7 Pawn is weak the G7 Pawn is going
to be weak and even though the king is
going to be safe the king side is going
to be on fire
so I think what we both underestimated
was this idea of edcd and queen B6
attacking the center and giving black
just enough counter play according to
the engine uh to keep the balance okay
the line here is Rook D3
Rook eight okay H6 now
so this gets really really sharp takes
takes E5 Rook E8 to pin the pawn
and my gut is that white is still better
here
but probably this was a better practical
chance than Queen C7 and I think the
idea that I'm happiest with that I'm
most proud of is this bishop D3 move
this I think was a really really strong
idea
because it does everything at once it
solidifies the center it puts pressure
on blackcenter and it gives us the
possibility of taking the bishop and
getting two Bishops against two knights
which in an open board is usually really
bad for the two nights and this is no
exception
um and then the next stage of the game
was all about provoking weaknesses on
the king side
and putting the queen on H3 another very
important ingredient
x-raying the Knight and creating D takes
E5 threads perhaps King B8 here was a
more resilient move but then we would
have taken on H7 and that's a free Pawn
so
just uh already a very bad position for
black but huge kudos takusha for
defending super well after giving up the
exchange
I think a lot of people would just like
instantly collapse but he found all of
the best chances I found this Rook F6 96
Rook F6 idea which essentially was the
game-winning idea
um yeah provoking weaknesses on the side
opposite where the king is is good too
that's a good takeaway from this game
right you you can win chess games by
attacking the side of the board that
doesn't have your opponent's king that's
totally valid in fact most of the game
was won on the king side ultimately I
was able to attack the king in the
center but it was because I provoked all
of the the dam really broke on the
f-file and on the king side
uh and okay I missed a forced win here
with the rook f8 and Knight and queen F6
but I think what I did was good enough I
think this is still completely winning
um according to the computer Rook takes
F7 and queen E5 offered the most
chances but obviously this just means
playing down a full exchange for Cafe
check is strong Knight is overloaded
okay this is obviously winning for why
just a full extra Exchange
uh so I really think I never truly left
it uh Let It Off The Hook and after The
Rook have three it's already totally
winning
okay
um before I conclude I'll check the
accuracy because I'm getting requests to
do that
all right 89.5 to 80.4 so pretty high
level game
um not without mistakes though obviously
there was one question what about Queen
G3 instead of Bishop G5
so Queen G3 here
I think black and simply Castle
yeah and if you play Bishop H6 then the
Knight can drop back to E8 I don't think
this is the end of the world because e
takes D4 is now a big threat the queen
on G3 is actually quite misplaced uh if
the bishop on D6 is not under Fire in
the game there was a knight on C4 that
was attacking that Bishop so it was safe
to put the queen on G3
but here I think Queen G3 black and
Castle black does not have to play
Knight H5 actually Knight H5 is a huge
blunder because the bishop takes F7
so anyways hope you enjoyed the game
guys thank you takusha once again this
will be up on YouTube
and I will head on out
thank you everybody for watching and uh
I'll see you tomorrow bye
[Music]